if you're trying to convince the public
to do something you have to say okay
how's this going to read um and what
message are we going to try to convey um
what will people respond to what would i
respond to if i was you know sort of an
objective member of the public and
so that's that that's really you know if
you're trying to change people's minds
or get people fired up about something
um then you got to think okay what's
that message what what's going to get
them really excited want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get the seven best
lessons from jeff bezos elon musk and
other highly successful entrepreneurs
enjoy
lesson number two find the path that
works for you with jeff bezos a lot of
people and i'm just not one of them
believe that you should live for the now
i think what you do is you think about
the the the great expanse of time ahead
of you and try to make sure that you're
planning for that in a way that's going
to leave you ultimately satisfied
so this is just my this is the way it
works for me and i mean this is
everybody needs to find that for
themself um
so i think there are a lot of paths
to satisfaction and you need to find one
that works
works for you lesson number three let go
with oprah winfrey letting go of energy
that's clouding your vision and holding
you back
it's a life practice that i learned long
ago that has freed me
so many ways it's a fact that holding
grudges against somebody who's done you
wrong or
replaying revisiting hurtful situations
in your head over and over only weighs
you down and prevents you from being who
you're meant to be
right now because you're still
energetically holding on to the past the
energy that you put into constantly
rewinding to the resentment why did they
do that why did they say that to me i
didn't deserve to be treated that way
all of that only keeps you stuck
it will never change what happened
you've gotta press stop
and reject the urge to keep replaying
so that you can then fast forward into
the now for yourself you know
a lot of people think
that holding on to things that
disempowered them
is going to somehow magically turn it
around
as i said in my message a couple weeks
ago about forgiveness
you have to release the notion give up
the hope that the past could have been
any different and you also must release
the idea that people would do what you
might do in any given instance this is a
big one i had to learn and relearn
before i actually got it expecting
people to do what you would do in a
situation only leads to your
disappointment not theirs they're going
on with their life
so let people be who they are and either
you accept it or you don't
not doing that keeps you stuck in a
circumstance that actually costs you
time costs you energy and i can
guarantee that oftentimes the person on
the other side of the bitterness you're
holding on to they're not even thinking
about you in fact they probably have
just moved on
they certainly aren't obsessing the way
you are think of it like letting go of
any bad habit that just doesn't serve
your well-being
not an easy task
taking the road to a more enlightened
healthy existence never is so
this is what i want to ask you to ask
yourself
why am i holding on to this
how is this serving me
and really think about the answer
maybe it makes you feel validated maybe
it makes you feel righteous
or maybe
taking on the pain is your way of
recognizing the injustice so that even
though it won't be made right it can at
least not be forgotten
then i ask you
again ask yourself
do you want to be right
or do you want peace
this was huge for me
the unfortunate fact is that having both
may not be possible and also you may
never get your moment of righteousness
so why wait for it choose peace
what i know for sure
is that in this world time
is a moving on and it's our most
valuable commodity you can never get it
back
so staying in that loop playing it over
and over in your head of hurt only
amplifies your pain let it go
exhale make room in your heart for
something that is uplifting
surround yourself with people who want
the best for you you have the ability to
shift the dna of your spirit and control
how you perceive life so why not lighten
your load and let it go
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four have the right
temperament with warren buffett stocks
sell at silly prices from time to time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
and
it doesn't take a high iq to figure out
that they're cheap but it does take a
temperament that's willing to step up
and actually act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business
if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
it
i mean i figured out very early you
don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament and
you have to be able to ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts
and decide
is this stock which is selling it x
worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find them you don't do anything so
that's my generalized stock tip no names
lesson number five use your gift with
tillman fertitta i think you know if you
know business or not and people ask me
should i go get my mba and you know what
i usually tell them you know if you need
to go get your mba if you don't have it
inside of you and you understand
economics and finance and and
and operations of business then you need
to go get it i knew that i didn't need
it it was just a god-given gift but also
remember i didn't get a lot of those
other gifts don't ask me to play that
guitar don't ask me to sing you a song
and don't ask me to draw you anything
but but you've got to know your
god-given gifts and everybody has it
everybody in this room has it right here
so do what you know was your god-given
gift and find a way to use that as your
path lesson number six do it better than
everybody with mark cuban you're talking
you know alluding to it earlier about
entrepreneurs being born or built you
know and i think
they're
i knew i was wired to be excited about
business
how or why i don't know but you know and
there's certain guys they have the
genetics to jump out of the gym right
certain guys you know that you know when
they golf they have the muscle memory
and and the discipline you know dirk
navisky may not be the most talented guy
in the nba but his discipline and his
focus to do what's necessary to be
successful he's willing to do and
combine it with being seven feet tall
and being skilled you know it makes him
an amazing basketball player so it's
understanding what your skill set is
finding the right place to use those
skills and then going for it you know
will that make you 250 grand it depends
if you pick the right industry but
whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody if you try to be a
little smarter than everybody if you try
to be a better sales person than
everybody if you try to be better
prepared than everybody you've got your
best chance because if you don't do it
and somebody else does
you know i have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know working i actually
work like someone's spending 24 hours
working 24 hours to take it all away
from you and and that's kind of the way
i look at it and lesson number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is be of service with grant
cardone listen to this i just
i'm happy if i can take care of my
family that is selfish man there's seven
billion people on this plate of planet
all different colors
different religions different ages
different problems they got places on
this planet where you can't get a you
can't get a glass you can't get a bottle
of water okay yeah but the guy that's in
the guy that's in london right now
thinking hey i got my flat pay for and i
got my two cars paid for and and i got a
good job and and yes yes me and my wife
are having some problems and the kid's
smoking too much weed but you know
things are pretty good that you're a
selfish bastard is what you are because
what you could be doing is is putting
another hour in early in the morning
another one at night
taking more risk
growing something maybe even disrupting
your business in your industry build a
freaking mega billion dollar business
leave a legacy and put hope put
hospitals and schools in place and
really really make a difference
can you walk through the 10x rule like i
know you sort of touched on points but
like just high level just because some
people
may not know like you're known as the
10x guy but what is a 10x rule at its
core yeah well the 10x rule first of all
the 10x rule is not an idea it's a way
of life
and and
people that go 10x are massive action
people
and and the premise of the book is
there's four levels of action there's
you don't do anything
you retreat
you do average
or you go 10x
now the first three the first three we
everybody knows somebody that does
nothing that you call them lazy
actually it's impossible to do nothing
but but just for conversation we'll say
a person does nothing we know that's not
gonna work going retreating
if you retreat your entire lifetime it's
going to be very painful retreating by
the way is actually
takes more energy
than
just normal activity just
the guys that get up every day and go to
work every day going backwards making a
decision to do something and not doing
it is is very painful a lot of wear and
tear going backwards
the third the third one
is the most damaging of all three which
is normal
levels of activity the acceptable
the average the the middle class the
norm
because you get lost these people get
lost they work every day they show up
every day they dig ditches every day
they do a good job every day they're
loyal every day
but they never get rewarded ever
number three is the story of my whole
life
that's where i operated the most of my
life most people normal levels of
activity
maybe just above normal just enough to
shine a little bit but dude i never went
for it
and and and so the 10x rule is like okay
how do i really take some risk here
how do i really put myself out there
so the middle class of america is
basically laid up on number three
being convinced to go to number two
and then end up with
basically they'll end up with number one
and how do you suggest somebody
takes that move from three to four yeah
so you what you would what you would do
is you you need to understand that
number three is is the the biggest
disaster that we have it's where
all wealth is created on the backs of
number three
uh the the the wealthy the wealthy
and this will happen again we'll come
out of this
this virus thing
people will go back to consuming again
and they'll go back to debt they'll go
back to borrowing money to buy things
they don't even need to impress people
they don't even know
because they're unsure about who they
are and where they're going
and so the the middle the middle of the
the spine of america the spine the
middle class of india when it develops
the middle class of china will fund the
wealthy
and because they do the normal things
the wealth wealthy do not do normal
things they do completely
you know they they do they don't they
don't save money wealthy people don't
save money they invest money wealthy
people don't spend time or manage time
they they
they take money that's useless they know
it's useless
and they buy
i'm gonna get a thousand employees
and then everybody's like well you know
that guy never works he hired 1 000
people to do work
this is an old story by the way you can
go back to the king tut
okay
i mean it's it's it's not a new story
it's like how do you get wealthy
well you commit to massive action how do
you do massive action
you only have 40 hours a week or
80 or 100.
uh elon musk says hey man 100 hours he
works 100 hours a week he he does the
video about the 100 hours he's like look
if i do 100 and you do 40 i went
he's a smart dude too by the way real
smart guy but he's nobody without the
risk without the big think and without
the massive action like look i spent
five years in college i went to college
because i wanted i thought the teachers
were going to teach me business
i love teachers okay teachers are great
people but
you can't
no business
if you're in a classroom
it's just it's just not possible it's
like my economics
my economics teacher
uh
there there's no way he could imagine
the the the fuel bill on my plane it's
just not real
you go to large sugar and say hey
how do you make sense of four jets
why would you do that
why'd you buy that building right there
that's the information i want see but
see but most us in this room we were
taught we had to go someplace and spend
four or five years there i'm not trying
to talk you out of school or university
but
the fact that it takes four years to get
out of university by itself is it is a
major problem it's a major problem you
know why the four years i'm trading time
for money
what do rich people do
they trade money for time i hear a lot
of guys saying right now like hey only
do the things you want to do dude i do
stuff i don't want to do every single
day
okay
so i don't know who these people are
that don't do the things they don't want
to do maybe they were given a business
or something but i'm going to tell you
something man if you don't do the things
you don't want to do you're not going to
grow your business you won't keep your
business i'm telling you you have to be
willing to do you got to be so obsessed
that you don't care
see
an obsessed person doesn't care if they
have to clean a toilet
uh-huh you know an obsessed person
doesn't care if they if they don't like
that activity but they have to do it
you're obsessed you're in it you do it
anyway no matter what like i remember my
mom told me one day she's like you know
grant
i love you just the way you are because
i tell i'm telling her about all these
dreams i have as a child right
yeah and i was reminded when my sister
told me like 30 years later you know
grant you've done a lot we love you just
the way you are and i'm like dude i
wonder how many times i've been told
that
you know and the fact is so what they
love me just the way i am
i don't
i don't love me just the way i am which
opens up to this whole field of people
that's like just love yourself the way
you are look if you're broke
you're not living on purpose you don't
like your job you can't get away from
your job dude if you're stuck in a house
you don't like
why would you want to love that
you should become obsessed with hating
it man it's obsessed or average one of
the two so pick just pick get a t-shirt
obsessed
or get another t-shirt average
which one would you be more proud
wearing right
yeah who do i want to be man who do i
want to be how do i how do i want to die
man i want to die all in look if you
want to be in business for yourself and
free you must learn to dominate
you cannot compete
okay how many were trained this
competition is a healthy thing
that message was not being delivered to
entrepreneurs
that message was being delivered to
consumers
there was somebody saying look the more
more oil companies we have the better
because it's good for the customer
right the the more technology companies
we have it's not just microsoft
the better for the customer and
interview
inventions and you know improvements and
products comes from competition but if
you're the one playing the game you want
to dominate the field so look here's the
deal i might be wrong in what i say okay
i might be wrong in the things i do in
my life and the business that i started
my family's told me not to start every
business that i've been involved in
every one of them every one of them was
a risk every one of them i had to take a
chance i remember my mom used to tell me
i wouldn't do that if i were you i
wouldn't do that if i were you i
wouldn't do that if i were you i'm like
mommy
you wouldn't do anything
well you wouldn't do anything except be
the mother a great mother to five
children
my mother wasn't an entrepreneur she
didn't have my dreams just because she's
my mom doesn't mean she dreams like me
would you agree
okay my mom was wrong about everything
she told me not to do
love my mom to death
okay unbelievable friend of mine she was
wrong
i needed to do those things okay steve
jobs needed to build this phone would
you agree did he help a lot of people
did he make some money while he was
doing it 119 billion dollars in five
years
in the bank cash
i'm not talking about price i'm talking
about in the in done in the bank sitting
there
okay brings a great product to the
marketplace domination or competition
total domination coca-cola competition
or domination
total domination okay exxon
total domination you see what i'm saying
you want to be in a dominating point
okay so what we got to do is we got to
get you thinking we got to get you
thinking like the dominators think how
do they act how does warren buffett act
what does warren buffett do with his
time all the time those are the people i
study today i don't study the people
that i went to school with the teachers
i went to school with i don't even study
my own family members
okay i'm looking for people that are way
up here that i can say hey what are they
doing because they're doing it right i
know a year ago
the last time i was on this interview
i think i just started working out every
day and my body was hurting all the time
i was in pain constantly you didn't want
to do it you were struggling dude my
ankles hurt my knees hurt my back hurt
my like like i had constant pain in my
body why'd you keep doing it
doing what working out no that that
that's no that i wasn't working before
you started working my body was in pain
i wasn't using my body i didn't use it
and it started to abandon me ah like i
wasn't paying attention to it you know
and it's like okay dude
you don't you don't want to pay
attention to me i'm going to make you
pay maybe i don't pay attention to you
you know or maybe i'll make you pay
attention to me yeah and then i got i
went to a pt uh three days a week that
really didn't do anything and i said you
know what i need to take responsibility
for this if i want to fix something that
that that's the code of my life do you
want to fix something take
responsibility yeah you take responsive
don't give it over to the physical
therapist the masseuse i was trying the
masseuse the masseuse never helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i i hired a guy named anthony he came
i said you come to the you come to my
place every day
same time every day here's the money
here take the money here's the schedule
i'm never going to miss a day wow
he travels with you two or no no no
this was in the first year got it
and um
you know it's been 14 months i have
almost zero pain in my body i had a guy
the other day asked me for some advice
okay you know these people that ask for
advice i know you know
you give it to them and they they don't
do it yeah yeah
he knew it was true it hit him
he's like i know that's right and then
he went and did something different this
is a big mistake people make man things
the best things that have happened to me
did not require
any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her because that adds
thought it adds time
and and
this is another bad piece of advice i
was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast
and and the faster you can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air
when it's landing slowing down is in
trouble when it's taken off it's it's at
risk that's interesting at flight at
full speed it's almost the safest thing
wants to fly
you know and and people people are being
conditioned to slow down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20 29 years old
because the the psychologist thought i
needed to slow down
she was scared of speed
i wasn't and at that time were you doing
well financially or doing grab is doing
great but everybody's saying hey you're
doing too much of this and you're doing
too much of that and you're gonna burn
and you're going to do this and people
were worried about me around me they
were going slow i was vibrating faster
than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumble bees
vibrate right they do things that are
impossible
so
you don't want to slow down
and and you want to move with speed and
certainty that means people need to know
what they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today talking
one today he'd been fighting man been
efforting 10 years he hadn't had a win
he won today that guy moves with speed
and certainty
you know winners move with speed and
certainty because they practice they
train they educate now fear is a really
powerful thing
but when you surrender and say i'm not
scared of fear it's unbelievably
liberating now i don't like to be
embarrassed
but i'm not scared of it but it wasn't
always like that for me when i was a
senior in uh
college there was a girl that i liked i
had to have my roommate
in college
call her up
and ask her to go to the formal as me
he literally called up said hey this is
jesse
that fast forward 20 years
i like this girl i'm trying to court her
she's the founder of spanx
i call the phone i call the her
assistant at spanx
and this is the same time that i'm about
to run a 100 mile race non-stop
in 24 hours for charity i call up i get
to the assistant and i said uh can you
tell sarah that i would love to wear
spanx
if in this 100 mile race if she would
give me a testimonial from my website
i don't want a testimonial i wanted
sarah
obviously the assistant goes hold on one
second puts me on hold and says sarah
there's some lunatic on the phone that
wants to run a hundred miles
in spanx
she says
i think i might know that lunatic and a
year later she married the lunatic
but in between that time when my
roommate had a call to ask this girl for
a date
to when i got sarah i call it like the
lamb mentality and the lion mentality
there was a lot of self-doubt
and self-doubt
is probably the biggest enemy to
creativity and the way you conquer
self-doubt is by doing things that make
you uncomfortable um no i just realized
that i'm an adrenaline junkie i love
newness i love challenges i mean that's
what makes me feel most alive
and i discovered that early on when i
was trying to get a record deal and just
getting rejection and i didn't i had no
connections my dad owned a plumbing
supply house in long island where i grew
up and we weren't connected to the music
world and i just love the thrill of
trying to do what everyone said i
couldn't do
there's no way you could you know
whenever all my roommates in college
were writing their resumes and sending
it out to all the companies they're like
why aren't you writing your resume we're
all like typing our resume why are you
working on it i'm like because i'm gonna
get a record deal and when they said no
you can't it just fueled me more to
want to go out and get it very cool so
what happened after uh the music success
you know you're reinvesting
and you sold the company did you stay in
the music world did you
so we branch out well we sold the
company to a public company and the
owner of this po of the public company
guy named bob silliman at sfx had a
private jet
and invited my partner and i on a trip
we were the youngest uh company that he
bought as far as we were 25 or 26 years
old we sold the company and he took a
liking to us kind of like
young guys invited us on a trip and went
on a private jet and um
as soon as we got on the plane we kind
of looked at each other and like
how in the world do we do this more
often like wow how do we get this right
and um
ultimately that one trip led to a
private jet business that we started
called marquee jet amazing so you just
decided that you're gonna launch a jet
company well we had this we had the idea
because we wanted to use it right so
like you know what even if no one else
signs up for this thing and we can fly
on a private jet that would be a win
but uh there's a completely different uh
skill set and business and industry that
you
didn't have any experience in i'm
assuming right i mean that's kind of a
theme for me i mean i think
one of the things i look back on my life
and i was in music i was in private jets
i've been in coconut water and all these
different things sports
um is that i had no prior experience in
any of that and it ended up being the
best blessing for me because no one
taught me or told me how to do it so it
was guaranteed that it would be done
differently interesting and that was uh
you know it guaranteed it would be
creative and different and unique so no
neither my partner and i or i had any
background and i mean we couldn't even
make a paper airplane right now
and we didn't have to buy a plane so you
weren't a pilot either on the zoo no no
okay but we had an idea you had a
passion for it we had an idea
um and
intuitively i think we both knew it
would work because we knew if we wanted
to use
this product that probably a lot of
people would want to use it and how can
we make it more affordable and bring it
to the masses
so what did you do tell me the problem
then what the solution was well the
problem was there was only three ways to
fry fly privately at the time you could
buy your own airplane which is
incredibly expensive
it takes out 99.9 of the world you could
buy a fraction of a plane which is like
a time share which is also very
expensive and it's a long commitment and
that's not we don't want to put a couple
of million dollars in for multiple years
we wanted to take like three trips a
year with our friends to golf yeah
or you could charter a plane and there's
all kinds of questions about like who
owns the plane who's flying the plane
what if the plane doesn't show up you
know inconsistencies
so we were like if we could just offer a
25-hour
solution
with none of the responsibilities of
owning your own plane you have to manage
it you have to schedule it you just like
call on demand it shows up
and you pre-pay for it and just work off
the hours it will work it's like the
uber for planes yeah but there was one
problem what we didn't have any planes
okay
so we we once we had the idea and we had
it all kind of baked we had to go find
out and find someone that could lend us
a fleet of airplanes right how many did
you want to start with uh well we sat
next to each other like you and i are
doing it
my partner asked me how many people you
think would buy this that you know and i
said i could probably sell 15. he said
all right put me down for 15 and say we
need enough to hold 30 people wow and um
we went to netjets which is owned by
warren buffett
and uh and berkshire and with this idea
are they based out of columbus yeah
whenever i fly in i see big netjets on
campus yeah
and um had this meeting to pitch this
idea that was gonna change my life and
they threw us out in about ten minutes
why
uh i think the direct quote is
sounds cool
if you guys think i'm giving two 27 year
olds my fleet of airplanes
it's not happening out of your mind yeah
and um
but his partner came out after the
meeting and said that was a great
meeting i said what are you talking
about we got thrown out in 12 12 minutes
he said rich santouli the ceo doesn't
give anyone 12 minutes and so if you
guys kind of just do this change this do
this
let's try it again so we did but instead
of coming back with a deck we brought in
our own focus group we literally just
lined up like eight chairs of athletes
entertainers agents people afford it
right and one by one they stood up and
explained why they wouldn't buy their
own plane why they wouldn't buy a net
jet fraud
and why they would buy this cart wow and
we got a deal and then a year later you
know we were
i think we had more customers than that
yet i don't need to be
in washington to figure out what the
washington post
newspaper has worked and i don't need to
be in new york to figure out what some
other company is worth that's it's it's
simply it's an intellectual process
and the less the less static there is in
that intellectual process really the
better off you are what is the
intellectual process the intellectual
processes
is
defining your level defining your area
of competence and valuing businesses
and then
within that area of competence
finding whatever sells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value and
there are all kinds of things i'm not
competent to value but there are a few
that i am competent to value have you
ever bought a technology company no i
really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one i
haven't understood any of them so you
haven't ever owned for example ibm never
owned ibm marvelous company i mean a
sensational company but i haven't owned
ibm
and so here is this uh technological
revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right past me
is that all right with you it's okay
with me
i don't have i don't have to make money
in every game i mean i don't know what
cocoa beans are going to do
i don't you know there are all kinds of
things i don't know about and that may
be too bad but uh you know why should i
know all about them i haven't worked
that hard on them in securities business
you literally every day have thousands
of the major american corporations
offered you
at a price and a price that changes
daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make
nothing is forced upon you so you there
are no called strikes in the business
the pitcher just stands there and throws
balls at you
and uh if you're playing real baseball
and it's between the knees and the
shoulders you either swing or you got a
strike call on you if you get too many
call i know you're out
in the securities business
you sit there and they throw a u.s steel
at 25 and they throw general motors at
68 and you don't have to swing at any of
them they may be wonderful pitches to
swing at but if you don't know enough
you don't have to swing
and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally you get
one right there where you want it
something that you understand and then
you swing and so you might not swing for
six months you might not swing for two
years i would
i would like to tell you of
two women
that
each sold the business
to berkshire hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with 2500
by a coincidence was the exact same
amount it was everything they had in the
world
and one of them
was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck the tags said
fort dodge iowa
the red cross
got her to fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had come
to the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years
and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided to move to omaha
so they came to omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of russian jews so she
started feeling more at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
frances
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school that day
and this woman rose blumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
50 at a time she sold used clothing to
do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd saved 2500
she went to chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream had always been to
open
a furniture store
and this woman without who had never
gone to school one day in her life
with 2 500
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she sold to me
in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
[Applause]
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin
lived
while she she worked for me until she
was 103. and
then i'm not saying then she retired and
she died the next year which is a lesson
to all the berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b
with her 2500
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew that she cared about her
customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business you
know my dad did upholstery on cars my
mom um so did whatever odd jobs um
but my dad was always like if you want
something you have to earn it and to his
credit he never said no you can't do
that so whether it was selling garbage
bags baseball cards stamps whatever it
was
he never held me back and so i think
that was as important as anything and
you know sometimes being young and
trying things you're so naive and you
don't know any better all you do is
learn and if you fail it doesn't matter
and so whether i was 9 10 12 16 21
the failures were irrelevant and you
know whether you're you know 9 12 16 21
22 24 you know i'm sleeping on the couch
you know i have a car with a hole in the
floorboard you know i'm i'm living like
a bum and like a student and so what did
i have to lose and so i think that
influenced me as much as anything so
you know my dad was like go for it you
know don't why not what have you got to
lose you know you have to sleep on a
different couch now let's pretend that
you're just about to graduate from
college right what's the advice
um you don't need the perfect job
you know um
part of the problem is you probably have
a hundred thousand dollars of debt right
um
and you to pay off for all that
um
and that's really [ __ ] up it's hurt
the economy it's hard you it hurts
everybody but
um
my advice general advice is assuming
there's not just the bills you got to
pay that are just
enormous is
you paid all that money to learn
now here's your chance to get paid to
learn and you don't need the perfect job
you need to get a job where you can make
some money
but also where you can learn and add
added to your portfolio of knowledge
added to your foundation because
as much as we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22
hell no
there's just no chance that the 30 year
old or even the 25 year old is going to
look back at the 21 or 22 year old you
and say oh that dude had it all together
and knew exactly what was up right
he's going to look back and go beer palm
what were you thinking you know and so
it
don't expect to have all the answers and
don't try to get the perfect job go out
there and get paid to have different
experiences and it's okay to jump from
job to job if it's not the right job you
are getting paid to learn flip it and
then use that to build your knowledge
and learn more about yourself learn how
to learn in business and see where it
can take you don't stop looking for a
job now
right just because things are difficult
doesn't mean you know that there's not
opportunity there because all it takes
is one
if you just if if you grind it out and
you continue to be persistent whether
it's emailing calling you know setting
up on seminars whatever it may be
however you can connect with people
applying for jobs to wherever however do
it you know every note gets you closer
to a yes and all it takes is that one
opportunity to propel you to where you
look to be
and you know and i guess adding to that
again like i said earlier there there's
so many new things going on when you
know when i came out of college way back
when um the was the last time that
unemployment was in double digits you
know my friends you know i remember
reading a story i went to indiana
university talking about how the
unemployment rate in northern indiana
was 20
and you know my friends were freaked out
like kids are today and i had to be
mobile right i had to go from indiana
back to pittsburgh my home down to
dallas in order to really get to a job
that i could platform and so as you look
for these things
you you really have to be more
adventurous if you will and be more
mobile and be more flexible and agile
and and that's not necessarily a bad
thing you don't have to get the best job
you don't have to get a perfect job you
just have to get a job and now all of a
sudden you're getting paid to learn and
you can platform that just like an mba
free agent right they might spend one
year or two year at one two years at one
team build their skill set to get better
and go to a better situation looking and
finding a job looking and finding an
internship looking at building your
skills set to prepare yourself for what
comes next
there's no better opportunity than now
in my early days i had a job i had a job
until i could figure out what it was
really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and
i'd gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air
and um
i was making twenty two thousand dollars
a year i thought i was in heaven because
i was making my age and my dream at the
time was gail and i used to say can you
imagine if you're 40 and you're making
40 000 would that be it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was mrs
chancellor's
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
vinnie and the caravel ice cream man
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
the stars themselves or whoever the
guests were but i felt like this is what
i'm supposed to do
all these years have been misplaced in
news because i couldn't relate to news i
was a news reporter and i'd be out on
the stories and i'd be crying with the
people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was uh august 14th 1978
and that was the beginning of fulfilling
the calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had
a problem with energy now when i was
working in news i used to be exhausted
all the time because i just exhausted
all the time because i hated it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and cause
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty two thousand
dollars a year
who's gonna play a black woman between
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make make that kind of money again
you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay everybody wants to be an
anchor woman at the time that was like
supposedly a big deal being an anchor
woman so i thought okay i won't i'll
just stay with this until i can figure
out what is the best thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do i felt like i
needed to be able to talk and at the
time the only thing was available was um
was uh like good morning america or the
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one bryant
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show he said that
to me
and um
interestingly enough he called me last
week because somebody else mentions it
to say he never said it but he did say
it and i said to him you know what if
you're ever told that you never forget
it if somebody ever says to you if
you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is if you can find what is your
passion if you find what you love you
never get tired or if you do get tired
you you're fueled by the energy of your
work so i know that i'm doing exactly
what i'm supposed to be doing at this
time
i also know that what the show can do
in terms of being um a voice and
changing the world it's just the
beginning of what this show can do it's
fun to do things like this but uh and
it's necessary to do things like this in
order to be able to do the bigger
grander things to change what happens to
to the face of children in africa for
example what happens to education with
kids in in this country so i believe
that um
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks to your heart through your
feelings and so you know what if you're
doing the right thing if it feels like
it's right to you and when you hit the
thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing
so how do i define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich you
famously started spanx with five
thousand dollars in your bank account
what was the hardest part about getting
spanx off the ground
um the hardest part about getting spanx
off the ground was definitely in the
very beginning when you have when you
first have an idea
as an inventor and you've thought of
something that doesn't exist and you
want to bring it into the world
there were two things that were
happening one was my own self-doubt was
a really hard part of the journey and
and then the beginning of all the
manufacturers that i was having to cold
call and talk to to try to get my
product made were all men and it was
much harder to explain and to try to get
them to understand the concept of what
the product was so i heard the word no
for two straight years trying to get it
made which then increases the self-doubt
that can happen
and one of the interesting things about
being an inventor is you don't go to
school for it there isn't an inventor
class you can't major in inventing and
so it's really a belief system in
yourself and the willingness to look
stupid or to have people laugh at you or
to fail
at something that you believe in you're
your own gut check on that and so it
takes a lot of confidence so that was
that was the hardest part of my journey
there was a lot of starting and stopping
and like am i crazy and everyone's
saying no and
but i you know i kept
picking myself back up to pursue it well
growing up my dad used to encourage my
brother and me to fail so at the dinner
table he would actually ask us what did
you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go and high-five me
and what it was such a gift what he was
doing i didn't realize it at the time
but he was redefining failure for me and
so failure became not about the outcome
but about not trying
and
so you know the fear of failure as we
all know as entrepreneurs is one of the
greatest fears in life it's one of the
things that stops us in our tracks and
keeps us from trying something um and so
i you know i incorporate that in my
philosophy at spanx we have we celebrate
failures we talk about them we have oops
meetings where i'll announce the oops
that i have and sometimes we have fun
with it we'll even attach
theme songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important to try to get the people that
you work with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of i want to protect my job and feel
like i'm not safe if i make mistakes
many aspiring entrepreneurs even in this
room struggle to find their initial idea
how do you constantly find ways to
invent new products and where does your
inspiration come from
um you know i
um
i mean i think of a lot of ideas at
traffic lights
i think of them all the time in
different places and i think it's part
of just being hyper observant
i um i like to
find white space i pay attention to what
are things that haven't evolved and why
you know like there's certain things in
our society that
updates itself and changes and and you
know constantly and then there's certain
things that it's not and so i'll ask
myself questions all day every day it's
just the way my brain works like i could
even be looking at a table and be like
why is the table like that when was the
table first created is that the actual
best design for a table or could there
be something different and you know
spanx went into men's and that was
randomly how that happened was because i
got curious that the man's undershirt
was created in 1918 and no one had paid
any attention to it since it was
literally the same thing and so i just
you know talked to my brother and my
husband about it and their undershirts
the necks stretched out or they were
boxy and bulky under clothes and i
thought oh i'm just going to add a
little bit of lycra to the cotton
undershirt for men and so the neck won't
stretch out and i'm going to taper it in
at the waist
so
ideas come to me like that like our
latest invention is arm tights
yeah ideas are really up clearly i love
my assistant who's my right hand lisa
she's been my right hand for 16 years
can attest to this but i have 99 pages i
don't know why it's 99 but she told me
the other day it's 99 pages single space
type of ideas
i need one more idea so um i i think of
ideas constantly on airplanes and car
you know talking to somebody and i email
it to myself and then i just keep them
and log them my dream is for there to be
many more female inventors i'm hoping
more more and more women will have the
courage to
take that risk it's a risk to invent
something you have to risk being made
fun of you have to risk looking like an
idiot
you have to do something that didn't
already exist which is scary i mean my
brain told me a million times who do you
think you are coming up with this then
one day you wake up and you go well what
if it is me it doesn't really face the
severe
uh threat of death uh due to the model 3
production ram
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time we would die
and it was extremely difficult
to solve them how close to death did you
come we were within
single budget weeks 22 hours a day or
like what how many hours working yeah
seven days a week
sleeping in the factory
i worked every day from i worked in the
boats in the paint shop general assembly
body shop you ever worry about yourself
imploding like it's just too much
absolutely
no one should
put this many hours into
work
this is not good
people should not work this hard i'm not
they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense
it's because my ears my brain
and my heart
so it's
this is not recommended for anyone i
just did it because if i didn't do it
then tesla
your chances would die like one of the
most difficult choices i ever faced
uh in life was
was in 2008 um
and um
i think i had uh
like
maybe 30 million dollars left
or 30 or 40 left in 2008 i had two
choices
i could
put it all into one company
and then the other company would
definitely die
or split it
between the two companies
and but if i split it between two
companies then both might die
um
and when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something
you're building something it's like a
child
um
and so it's like which one
am i gonna let one stop to death
i can bring myself to do it so i put i
split the money between the two
fortunately thank goodness uh they both
came through there's a friend of mine
who's got a great saying about creating
a company um
which is uh creating try trying to build
a company and have it succeed is like
eating glass and staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then then reality sets in things don't
go as well as planned customers aren't
signing up the technology or the product
isn't working as well as you thought
and
and then that can sometimes be
compounded by a recession
and
it can be
very very painful for several years um
so i think
um
frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance i was flying from the
british virgin islands no sorry from
puerto rico to the british virgin
islands and
um
and i was 28 years old and i been away
from home for three weeks and i had this
gorgeous lady waiting for me and um and
american airlines
um announced that they are banned
they're not going to fly the flight till
the next morning they didn't have enough
passengers and i was damned if i was
going to wait till the next morning and
so i went to the back of the airport and
i borrowed a blackboard
um and i scribbled virgin airlines as a
joke 39 one way to the british virgin
islands and
went around all the passengers and i
managed to fill up my first flight
and
when i got to the bbi the guy on my left
you know turned to me and said you
sharpen up the service a bit and you
could be in the airline business um
and
the next day
um uh anyway the night went well the
next day
the next
she's now my wife 40 years still 40
years later
and then the next day i rang up boeing
and i said um
uh i'm thinking of going to the airline
business in fact i've just had my test
flight um they
uh do you have any secondhand 747s for
sale and um
the person who took the phone call
um
i thought he was going to put the phone
down on me but he you know he hung on in
there
so he said well you know what what does
your company do and i said well you know
we're a record company we've got the
rolling stones we've got the sex pistols
and again he didn't sound very very you
know they said what's the name of the
company and i said virgin and there was
a long pause and he said
well we'll send a salesman to see you
but um with a name like virgin i i just
hope your airline goes the whole way
one time when you were doing hot air
ballooning uh you weren't sure whether
you would survive with the ballooning
adventures i was doing something that
that nobody had done before
i was um
you know trying to you know fly across
the atlantic or the pacific or or go
around the world in a in a balloon
i was flying at you know 40 000 feet in
in the jet stream um you know with one
with one other person pierre lindstrand
um
and
uh
and
you know the technology was completely
unproven they were
we were the test pilots that was more
dangerous things could go wrong and they
did go right you set a number of
guinness world records for that but in
hindsight do you have any regrets about
taking those risks
on the hot air balloon
it's interesting um you know my son and
daughter now
uh
are setting themselves big adventures
every year um dragging their dad along
on some of them you know and i think as
a family we feel
you know live life live life to its full
and
um and you know you can
you know you can
uh you can you can die in a road
accident you can die on a just a normal
bike ride um and quite often when you're
actually
completely focused on an adventure um
the
it's less likely in some way that you're
going to die
in an adventure because you're you're
ready and sharp and
and know how to deal with it but what
transpired for me when i was probably 15
was reading in the late 60s about the
founding of a company called intel craig
barrett the ceo of intel is here
and it developed as a role model for me
of what i wanted to do
of course at that stage of my life it
seemed very very far away
but
many years later
and i'll tell you later that i'm a big
fan of risk
i learned hang gliding
and while watching a movie about hang
gliding i saw this quote
this dedication of the movie and it went
something like this
dedicated to those who dare to dream the
dreams
and then are foolish enough to try and
make those dreams come true
in the operative word here is foolish
because unless
you transcend what's traditional and i
think we've talked about this earlier
unless you go past what's reasonable
you're not going to get
some place
different
most people
do the traditional thing and get to
traditional places
there is another way building a team is
the hardest thing for an entrepreneur to
do because
very often they don't know what they
don't know
right they they know their area of
specialty really well
but other areas they think they
understand but they don't and every area
is more complex and more nuanced
than it appears to somebody you know to
i see so many entrepreneurs who think
marketing is about a press release or an
advertising campaign it's not
it's much more nuanced and sophisticated
than that
so team building is very important
some entrepreneurs do a really good job
of growing larry page is an example mark
zuckerberg is an example of
being better at new functions as they
come up
ins and and and also they've done a
really good job of adding people who
they can learn these new areas from
what i find is some
entrepreneurs assume they know the
answer
and that's very dangerous and others
know they don't know
and they hire the people who they can
learn from
but they can still apply their
entrepreneurial style in these new areas
sometimes it makes sense for the
entrepreneur to keep being ceo and
driving the whole vision usually that's
the best course but some entrepreneurs
can't think broadly enough to do that
and they can't grow fast enough the
thing i think that i did right from the
beginning
and even
now in this moment
now that my circumstances are very
different
is i've
i've always known and this comes from i
think my faith deep down inside i've
always known that like what i'm called
to do isn't about me
and so
for me it's it's what's fueled me
in all the times
when it seemed like no one else believed
in me like i knew why i was doing this
um was so much bigger than myself and to
really shift culture and beauty and even
now even just saying like oh my gosh you
started something in your living room
and someone pays you a billion dollars
for it like if i think about that i
can't even process it right
i can't even handle it because what
happens is i'll start thinking of like
oh but you know
i don't i didn't come from the right
family no one of my
neither my parents went to college all
those things that we tell ourselves
about why
we're not the person that has those kind
of things happening to us um
and so so two things one i i often
remind myself that like anything that's
ever been created that's great or that's
a brand we all use now or a big business
like it was all created by somebody
really at the end of the day who's just
like you and me just like all of us
every single thing right so like why not
i'm not you why not yeah and then and
then the other thing is like when i
really start to um
kind of like get in my own head about it
because it is really
strange you see like oh yeah like
all those things like um
i i make it not about my i know i remind
myself it's it's not about me right so
for my book for example i'm donating 100
of the proceeds but like like i the the
book is to serve right and like i i
believe at the end of the day that we
get in life like what we give you know
what i mean along this whole journey
i've known it's bigger than myself even
now like i just i don't know i believe
that you know i'm called to serve and
and to
like i feel blessed to have accomplished
one of my biggest dreams but my my
biggest
my biggest driver now is helping other
women um
and especially their entrepreneurs and
really other women like accomplish their
greatest dreams i also knew that like of
course i'd have to work really really
hard if i was ever gonna make it of
course i'd have to get back up every
time i got knocked down on the journey
but i knew if i was gonna make it like
the most important thing came down to me
believing that i could
and for me
you know
and here's the thing a lot of times we
hold ourselves back because we say
things to ourselves like oh i'm not
qualified or oh i feel this like dream
on my heart to whatever it is launch a
podcast whatever it is but it's like oh
but i'm you know don't know how and i
don't know i have no connections and all
the things we tell ourselves and
for me
in a way it almost made no sense that i
created a beauty company right and
just the idea of it because i didn't
know anything about it i knew no one in
the industry but every time i get still
like for me um and you know no matter
what people believe whether it's they're
hearing the universe talk to them or god
talk to them like for me i hear it
through my own intuition how did you get
through like tactically to a sale in the
encyclopedia world like people don't
want to hear from you so like how do you
overcome that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was out for three and a half years and
the way it worked in those days it was
commission only so the way it worked is
you went for an interview they told you
all you could possibly make off
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing well when you got in the
field you remember parts of it you knock
on doors you're not quite sure of
yourself a lot of doors are closed in
your face but what happens after a while
you start getting used to it and you see
what you can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other sales
people what you see what you do what did
i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give 10 presentations to sell
one book but then when you get better
and better at it through your
experiences and losses along the way it
sharpens you up where all of a sudden i
got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
were the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people don't know these things
look someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're on or
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile is the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes people change and so
at what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for what was
the point where you guys said hmm like
let's do this like what was the well we
were planning to do it because i knew
the business i was in marketing sales
and structure and had connections with
uh product development
and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world
very advanced in what he did however he
didn't do business it was the perfect
combination
guys together we're just the best of
friends and we knew we could do it uh
obviously we started out with nothing we
made the decision let's just let's just
make this happen and as you will see in
your guests we'll see when they look at
good fortune the movie and it's on
itunes it's on amazon all those when you
look at it it's a whole story of
starting in america with nothing a
couple times and making things happen
because of what you believe in but the
important thing is even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we do why not
shake your hand today sure you betcha
but i applaud you
i have had before co-partners
in some businesses i've tried and not as
good as my partner paul mitchell but in
other businesses and they didn't turn
out to be what i thought they would be
so if you have a partner one you've got
to be friendly to one another you also
have to have your boundaries where okay
i live my life you live your life we
can't live it all together we're
together we have a certain goal now if
you do have i call it a challenge
opposed to a problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively
don't attack on it instead it's much
easier to say
well you know liz uh
you're a wonderful person we've done
some really great business together but
with all due respect when i came in here
i had a great idea i wanted to tell you
and you kept on cutting me off and it
made me feel bad liz you know as well
that just made me feel bad and i know
you'd like to hear it i just wanted to
share that with you you share your
feelings with the person if they have an
id you don't think it's any good you
could say you know that's that that
that's a great idea i could appreciate
where you're coming from always validate
the person however can we look at this a
little differently maybe we can enhance
it and build upon it and you come in
with your two cents always respect the
other person what are your core values
personally and professionally
uh core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you that's the basis for most
religions but they get sometimes carried
away in rights and rituals but that's
the core value do unto others as you'd
have others do unto you and then it's
the feeling of knowing that success
unshared is definitely failure in other
words when you make it it's not really
just about yourself making it hey if you
make it you know you made it but along
the way one of the great lessons to
learn
is it's not all about you
it's about your ability to be of service
to this planet while you're here and by
saying me me me look what i did this is
me hey here's my building my name's on
it you know i did this you didn't by
doing something like that it kind of
takes away from how genuine you are and
because people don't like to just listen
to people talk about themselves how
great they are they want to know
incorporate it to make them successful
also or do something a little different
and i think that's very very important
you know i think that uh i think there
definitely are things that one can
iterate on but the the core thing is to
have a great product and then you can
always improve and and iterate on that
in all sorts of ways and i think you
know i think um even in in the tech
industry um
what's striking is how
um
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were it was
just they had a great product and then
years later they were able to optimize
it in all sorts of
all sorts of ways um
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product
i think that that rarely works um i
think it's always worth asking you know
where you're going to go with this
business um and so i think we're always
focused on very short time horizons
because you have to figure out a way to
get through the next month the next
quarter uh you know how do you get some
customers how do you how do you track
but it's it's always worth thinking
ahead you know five to ten years you
know why will this be a really valuable
business in five to ten years
and you know how's the competitive
landscape going to develop how's
technology going to develop how's the
world going to develop um these are hard
questions to answer but i think um i
think i think i think the the great
entrepreneurs that i know always have
some perspective on it and it might be
wrong but it's just this is what's going
to happen and then it's sort of well
reasoned and and so you have a you have
a plan it and you know it's uh when i
when i was playing chess uh you know in
junior high school one of the early
lessons i learned was a bad plan is
still always better than no plan at all
right and so
you know have a plan you can always
change it but don't don't just pretend
that uh that you have no clue about
what's going to happen and that
everything about the future is random if
you if you sort of say that everything's
random and out of your control that's
that's that's the way you set yourself
up for failure i think you should be
doing something you're passionate about
so the question is always
you know when i give my younger self
advice you know if would i still go to
stanford and this will go to stanford
law school
possibly but i think a lot more about
why i was doing it was is it just uh you
know you know i was on this super
tracked for myself i ended up at a big
law firm in new york uh in my eighth
grade junior high school yearbook one of
my friends wrote and i know you're going
to get into stanford in four years i
went to stanford four years later went
to stanford law school ended up at a big
law firm in uh in new york where on the
outside everybody wanted to get in on
the inside everybody wanted to get out
when i left after uh seven months and
three days
um one one of the one of the people uh
down the hall from me said it was you
know really reassuring to see that it
was possible to escape from alcatraz
which you know all you had to do was
really just go out the front door but um
but so much of um our identity gets
wrapped up in the competitions we win
and um that um and when you compete
um and i think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition when you compete you
do get better at what you're competing
at if you take lots of sat test prep
classes you'll get a better score on the
s.a.t
um and when you compete you get better
at uh beating people on the narrow
things you need to beat them on but um
but you often it often comes at this
very high price of of losing sight of
what's uh what's truly valuable and
important and meaningful
which is
well i think passion because well
there's sort of all sorts of other all
sorts of things that that could be that
but but i think um i think it often the
the i think it often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path because uh so i think um you
know there's obviously financial version
where you get to be have a monopoly like
business there's a the meaningful
version i think is always counterfactual
where if you weren't doing this
would you know it's great to be working
on problems where if you weren't working
on them nobody else would do them you
know if you're working at the fourth
online pet food company the 10th in film
solar panel company the 1000th
restaurant in philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it someone else would um you know
if you're working at uh
at something where it's the only thing
of its kind in the world that's very
meaningful if if we weren't if we and it
could be for-profit non-profit all sorts
of context if we weren't doing this this
problem would absolutely not be tackled
i think that's the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful
so let's say you're trying to select
people for your teal fellowships or
maybe to work for one of your companies
or to start a new company with
and just you peter thiel as a judge of
talent
what trade do you look for in that
person that is being undervalued by
others a lot of what you're looking for
are like these almost zen-like opposites
so you want people who are both really
stubborn and really open-minded okay
that's like like a little bit
contradictory um you want um you want
people who are um you know sort of
idiosyncratic and really different but
then who can work well together in teams
um and so this is again sort of maybe
not 180 degrees opposite but it's like
175 degrees and this is why you like
kegel
not not not i don't like hagel that much
but um
but but um but so but so i think it's um
so if you sort of focus too much on one
or the other end of it you'd get it uh
completely you would tend to get it
completely wrong so uh so i i but i i
like to get things where you get these
combinations of unusual traits so uh so
if you have people with some you know
really interesting
very different idea
that suggests okay we're in sort of in
the
idiosyncratic category then the
important question becomes okay would
they actually be able to function
socially and execute and then then maybe
the teamwork question you'd ask would be
what's the pre-history of this company
how did you meet how long have you been
working together and if there's a long
pre-history that would be that would be
good on the other side so i think it's
always getting these combinations right
this is the problem with college and is
that they teach you the theoretical side
of everything
for the person that's working for you
but it doesn't teach you to be the ceo
the practical side and the young
entrepreneur whether you're trying to go
up the corporate ladder or you are doing
it you're on and it's just the simple
things of and these are some of my great
tillmanisms from the book and why
harpercollins came to me and asked me to
write this book was
know your numbers okay you've got to
know your numbers there are no spare
customers we're all in a consumer
business
people watching this podcast for you or
me serving casino customers restaurant
customers hotel customers there are no
spare customers we're all after the same
consumer to the 95 5 rule that 95
percent of everything is right so look
for the five percent that's wrong i
think you know if you know business or
not and people ask me should i go get my
mba and you know what i usually tell
them you know if you need to go get your
mba if you don't have it inside of you
and you understand economics and finance
and and and operations of business then
you need to go get it i knew that i
didn't need it it was just a god-given
gift but also remember i didn't get a
lot of those other gifts don't ask me to
play that guitar don't ask me to sing
you a song and don't ask me to draw you
anything
but but you've got to know your
god-given gifts and everybody has it
everybody in this room has it right here
so do what you know was your god-given
gift and find a way to use that as your
path uh i know there's a paddle for
everybody's ass and and i talk about it
in the book and and i think that's
probably
you know
what i could give everybody out there
who's ever made a few dollars uh you
better watch for even today you know
when i came out yesterday was number 140
on the forbes list 4.9 billion i still
get up every day and worry and worry if
that paddle is going to get my ass okay
and the day you stop worrying and you
just spin freely the paddle is going to
get you because you don't know what's
going to happen is our government going
to chain to a socialist government is is
all of a sudden somebody's going to come
out and the millennials say we're never
going to eat meat again right
right you know you just don't know but
but but we've seen some crazy things
happen in our world and during my
lifetime
and and uh
in your lifetime already so so so
remember i mean i'm the one who grew up
and you had one telephone and in the
house and and if you wanted to talk to
your friends you went to that telephone
and and it was just a different world i
am part of who i am is because of
relationships and and and relationships
and the investment banking world and you
mentioned somebody a few minutes ago
that's friends with both of us uh they
were always there for me now always
performed and if you perform people want
to be there for you i had other
great relationships in the m a world
that worked with me when i was looking
at deals because they knew i was
credible but having great relationships
in the investment banking world that you
developed and i told one of them once i
said you got to make your friends your
friends
and and you got to know who to trust and
who have faith in but but absolutely uh
i would not be where i am today without
relationships because we knew we could
always count on each other
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more amazing lessons from
mega successful entrepreneurs check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there and so that's another
thing you always need to be stepping
back and saying if i i'm an expert i'm
an expert in
launch vehicles or whatever it is
i i need to step back
and say okay